uh okay hello everyone let's get started
so last time
what we did was ntk
um the neural tangent kernel approach
and
um
so today we are going to continue with
that to finish the last part of the
neural tangent kernel approach and then
we talk about on the so-called implicit
regularization effect
um so last time
briefly we recall that last time we have
done the following
so
we have claimed that there are two steps
three steps
and this analysis using the ntk approach
so one step is that you say
um
you say that F Theta X is close to G 3x
in some neighborhood
oh wait
oh sorry
there are too many steps in this setup
so I always forgot some step
the worst step I would forget is that I
forgot to record on then like other you
know this one you can remind me but if I
forgot to record then nobody would
remind me so so that's what that's the
thing I check every time okay cool and
I think this is recording this is
recording and you can you can hear me on
Zoom right maybe
um
[Music]
nobody seems to say anything but it
sounds like the
it's recording the
it's receiving audio okay
um so
so let's
um so so last time we we saw that if in
some neighborhoods
um Theta
around B zero uh you can have accurate
accurate of approximation and recall
that the b0 was something like a
neighborhood of size something that
depends on the sigma so B to the zero
was defined we showed that if you look
at
the neighborhood where
you have some say whereas data is close
to set a zero with distance something
like
square root n over Sigma
then you indeed have something
um
I guess you get how well the
approximation is I think the
approximation in this neighborhood
the approximation
our
is something like beta squared and beta
n over Sigma Square
right that's what we had and and also in
this neighborhood
two in this neighborhood
so there exists a global minimum
with our
zero
nobody seems to respond to my requests
about confirming that the audio is
working but I don't know
there are only four people here oh okay
oh
okay so you can hear you hear me okay
thank you so much
um great great thanks
it's just uh sometimes I I got Paranoid
by this
um okay thank you so much okay cool so
um
all right so this is what we proved last
time and we discussed you know this
quantity is the key thing right beta
over Sigma square is the very key thing
and if it goes to zero then that's great
because your arrow becomes smaller and
smaller
um
oh I see I cannot hear you that's the
problem
I see
probably now I can hear you I I think my
speaker is very
the the volume is very low okay cool
thanks so much
um
so
and now the third step as we discussed
last time is that and we have discussed
various cases where this Beta Sigma
square is goes to zero uh we discussed
two cases
and today we are gonna
talk about the third step where we show
that optimizing
optimizing
optimize the
uh with
I have data with any network is
similarly similar to optimizing
with G Theta
um and in some sense the only thing you
care about is an analysis of the
optimization for f Theta but you want to
do this kind of like relationship so
that you can make the optimization
easier
and we also briefly discussed you know
what we do with this optimization I
think there are two ways right one way
is you
um there are two ways to deal with the G
Theta so I think there are two ways one
is something like using strong convexity
and the other is using the only the
smoothness
and and today we're going to focus on
this case which doesn't require too much
of the background about optimization
all right so now let's go into the
detail
so by the way I think a small remark
before I go into the detail so why you
care about the steps three in some sense
right so a priority there is no another
reason you know okay so there's one
reason which is that you want to
understand what happens when you
optimize over in your Networks right but
suppose the solution the understanding
suppose at some point like we are at the
moment where we want to prove this
number three but we haven't succeeded
but you probably would question yourself
you know why I care about such a answer
right even I prove this answer why it's
interesting and the answer is yes it's
not that interesting because you know if
you prove that optimizing overnight work
is the same as optimizing some linear
model like a kernel method then why not
just using kernel method right so so and
and it turns out that that's indeed true
like you know if you use kernel method
um you are not it's not going to work if
you're optimize the right work in this
way in this particular initialization
with this particular learning universe
and so forth it wouldn't work as well
either so so in some sense this is um
um so this whole theorem the value of
this theorem is more is only for showing
that under certain regime optimizing
overnight work is the same as optimizing
over linear model but but there's no any
like bigger impact in some sense like
just because you are optimizing the
invite working a weird regime which is
the same as which is the same as
optimizing kernels and in this regime
nothing works very well
but still you know for the technical
reason let's do try to go through this
you know it's not super complicated and
I think in some sense the techniques is
kind of also it's kind of useful because
um partly because I think it's somewhat
surprising because at the first place
you wouldn't probably believe it right
why you believe that optimizing the
right work in any case would be similar
to optimizing kernels and this shows
that that's possible in some cases even
though that case is not that
um informative or that that kind of like
useful
okay so
um let's analyze um um so we start with
you know the first step we start with
like analyzing the the optimization with
G Theta
so
and and this is really just a you know
um linear regression right it's really
understanding optimization of linear
regression
so you take so the problem is really
you're taking mean of this y back minus
V Delta Theta
2 num Square
uh with GD
and just to briefly recall the notation
so Phi is this feature Matrix which is
of Dimension n by P
so this is n by P Matrix and each row is
something like write F Theta
0 x
I
trans transpose I see you put all of
these as rows you know what exactly this
three Matrix is you know it doesn't
matter so much anymore for the for the
rest of the discussion because V is just
a matrix and Delta Theta is the
difference between Theta and Theta zero
and we're just optimizing over Delta
Theta
and what you do is we just take winning
descent and you'd say
um then the grading descent
is you take the
ingredient and the gradient is V
transpose
transpose times y back
minus V Delta Theta
right this is the green update and
one of the kind of the features of this
analysis is that you are looking at the
convergence
the changes
in the output space
and in some sense this is kind of like
to some extent this is the the spirit of
the kernel method you're looking like
not the parametric you don't look at a
parameter space but you can output space
you know and when you look at the output
space it's kind of like you're looking
at the function space
to some extent but
um you know what does that mean that
means that you're looking at the the
output Y at time t plus one
um so this is defined to be just a v
times Delta Theta i t plus one
I guess by definitely let's define the
version with T so and you look at how
you change the residual
um over time right so
you compare
your output at time t with the corrected
output at uh uh Target output where uh
way back
and how does this change over time and
this is just
the definition
and you plug in
the definition of theta T which is Delta
Theta T minus ETA
on fee transpose y back minus feed Delta
Theta
minus y back
and now this you know requires some kind
of like real arrangement to make it look
cleaner and how do I rearrange this I
guess I'm going to
first group everything
um
about Delta Theta so you group this term
and term related to this
this is also Delta Theta t
so so you get
fee
minus Eta Phi transpose Phi
I think I'm missing something here
what's wrong with this one moment sorry
yeah okay I think I'm right so
so if you look at what is Multiplied in
front of this term there's this one this
one right so there are three things
multiplied in front of the Theta t
so this is the multiplier in front of
security and then you look at the
multiply in front of y y back then you
get minus
ETA fee Phi transpose
um plus identity
right back and and interestingly
this you can write it as
I minus ETA V transpose
sorry m
C
you can write this as Beta Phi Phi
transpose
times V
Delta 30 minus I minus ETA
Phi Phi transpose
right back
and then you get I minus ETA
if you transpose
Delta Theta T minus y back all of these
are basically just a standard
calculation
um I think some version of you know if
you see take some version of like a
linear regression course then probably
you would have seen you have seen this
you got this
so that's the the update that's the
recursion for the residual of the of the
output
and you can see what happens is
basically your residual in the previous
round got multiplied by this Matrix and
what this Matrix is this Matrix is
a matrix that is smaller than identity
because you have I minus something and
this something is a PSD Matrix
so you are shrinking your residual in
some way every time so and you can
quantify how fast you are shrinking so
if when
ETA is less than 2 over Sigma Max
free free transpose
and I Define let's define this quantity
let's call it one over two tall Square
then
you can show that
this convergence then
I minus Eta Phi Phi transpose can be
shown to have
operator Norm less than
uh
1 over
ETA
tall Ethan
I think I have some
interest Sigma Square
so and then you have Okay so this I'll
show this in a moment but suppose you
have this then you know that YT well
High T minus y y
and two Norm is less than
the operator normative of this Matrix
times
sorry let's take this 32 t plus one
while I'm back to normal so this is less
than one minus E times Sigma Square
and Y at T minus y
two norm and this is if you do a lot of
recursions you get one minus ETA Sigma
Square to the power t
plus 1 times y over x 0 minus y to Norm
so you have an exponential decay of
error
yep yes that's that's a good point so
Sigma
value of Phi
and let's let's prove this right now so
this let's say this is number one but
suppose you have number one then you
have all of this exponential decay right
so now let's prove the number one
so
um
how do we do that
so
establishing
one
so intuitively it's just really that
this is a hxx PSD so that's why you
subtract something right your operator
normally is less than one no right so
but we need to make sure we know exactly
how small it is right it cannot be if it
has to be strictly less than one that's
why we needed this equality one and and
to see this I guess you know
um there are multiple ways to see it but
I think the way I tend to think about it
is that so first of all Sigma
is Sigma mean of V which is also the
sigma mean
of Phi Phi transpose square root
this is just by the standard property of
the singular values so
um
um so so I guess you know one way to
think about this is that if you look at
the eigen single
either eigenvalue or singular value
because this is a PSD Matrix so it
doesn't matter
value of
transpose
then let's say suppose the eigenvalues
are Tau 1 square up to Tau n Square
and then Tau 1 square is equals to Tau
Square that's a definition of the sigma
Max right and until
n square is the sigma Square this is my
definition of the sigma mean
and and you and then the I minus we care
about this Matrix
so this one has
a singular eigenvalue or singular value
um y minus ETA Tau y square up to 1
minus ETA Tau n Square
right this is just because
um
I have single value one so
I'm not sure whether this is
do you think these requires a proof this
is just because I guess there are many
ways to see this for example
I guess the best way for me to see it is
always a tick
eigen decomposition you see C is U Sigma
V transpose where Sigma is this Matrix
with Tau one up to token and then I
minus V Phi transpose ETA transpose it's
just a
uh I minus
ETA
U Sigma Square
U transpose
right and and
I is equals to UU transpose
transpose and then you get U times I
minus
ETA Sigma Square U transpose and this is
the SPD
for
or the eigenic conversation or SVD for
uh
for I minus ETA VV transpose and as
that's why what's inside is the
eigenvalues or the singular values for
the resulting Matrix
right so and and then now you bound this
right so so there but but if you care
about operating number the largest the
absolute value of the eigenvalue right
so so basically that's why I minus
eta-free transpose
the Opera Norm is less than the max over
J
one minus ETA Tau J Square
absolute value and I think your ETA is
guaranteed the choice of ETA is trying
to guarantee that you never get to the
negative side
you try to make sure the ETA is less
than 1 over 2 Tau square and tau is the
largest one
so that's why even the largest one is
even as the largest tall will not make
the one minus either tall Square
negative so everything is positive so
then
then this is a
uh
this is just equals to 1 minus ETA
taught in Square which is equal to minus
ETA Sigma Square
Okay so
sounds good
um yeah in some sense these are
um
you know sometimes the basics of
optimization but this course doesn't
require optimization that's why I'm
providing some some basic tools here so
and
right so
okay so so basically we are done with
the the analysis of this linear
regression right after you have this you
you know that you are the your arrow is
decaying expansion very fast and then
after sufficient number of iterations
you error is small right so so basically
maybe let's call this two so from two
you have after
for T is at most
something like log one over Epsilon over
ETA Sigma Square iteration
so uh your error y hat T minus y
uck
is less than Epsilon times the initial
I think and and you can take Epson to be
small so that you can
you can have a you know if you can take
options to be very small right because
it's logarithmic decay of errors
Okay so
so this is analysis for G and now let's
talk talk about analysis for f right so
so
you'll see that uh
now analysis for f is very similar to
this but with some some tweak maybe let
me State ethereum just so that we have a
formal statement somewhere so there
exists
a constant say c0
and 0 and 1.
such that
when this key quantity B's weight over
Sigma square is less than c0
for sufficiently
small
ETA and ETA could this could depend on
which could depend on
Beta Sigma maybe the dimension P so and
so forth I think you can have a concrete
Bound for the for how small ETA has to
be but I I'm just lazy I want to you
know I'm lazy but like I want to hide
these details you know I'm also lazy but
I also want to have these details uh so
that it's not too too complicated for
for the for the expectation but when you
have sufficient small ETA then uh in T
is equals to O of log 1 over Epsilon
over ETA Sigma Square steps
um the empirical laws for the F7 t
is also less than is less than absolute
so so so the empirical loss for the for
the new network is also has having this
error episode
so how do we do this so the I guess we
have kind of discussed the intuition
already so the intuition is that you
always have
um try to kind of relate this to the G
so and here by relating to the G
basically you just try to follow what I
mean is really you try to follow the
proof you had before like just try to
imitate as much as possible and and of
course there will be some differences
and then you deal with the differences
so
so I think one difference is that by the
way this is a proof sketch because I'm
going to Omit some small technical
drawings which is not super important
um so the important thing is that
um you have a changing
fee in some sense
so
um this is what's the difference in new
networks when you have networks compared
to
um
the
um the the the linear regression case so
you'll see why this is the case so
suppose you define this fee fee sub V
superscript T to be the
the the kernel at time t
right so this is the
this is the ntk kernel when your Taylor
expand at time t
and if you tell expand time T then
then the gradient descent I think we
have discussed this before but now you
can see it explicitly I think I've
claimed that if you tell expand at time
T then the gradient with respect to the
approximation is the same as the
gradient with respect to the
um on the original phone the the the the
new ice work price so this is what I I
think wrote
at the background here this is the
remark so if you tell expander time T
then the gradient with recognized work
is the same as the grading respect
linear function
um this is just because these two things
are great uh this is this is a these two
things are great at this point up to
first order so that's why even you
compose with a loss function up to first
order they still agree
so
um
so and here you can even see that
explicitly so suppose you write down the
gradient
of the
of the loss function at I'd say that t
then what you get is that you have one
over n
uh
you can do the chain rule so you can get
this is
y i minus F Theta t x i
times gradient f
Theta T times x i
you can verify this just even without
having using a remarket hat right this
is just a chain rule and uh and then
this is equals to
um
if you write if you view this as the
this is from the feed this is the the
iso of the feed right
the yes so this corresponds to i03 and
this corresponds to the the difference
of maybe let me write this more
explicitly
this is why
I minus y
i t
right times the gradient
sorry
and then if you write this as a vector
for matrix multiplication form you get
VT which corresponds to this one
and then you have y
V minus
y hat
t
and there's a wall right in front of it
so that's the gradient
and that means that the update rule
facility
I think I somehow say that here
uh yeah
I guess I'm going to use CLT instead of
data 30 they are the same right they are
just only different Optical translation
so 30 plus 1 is equals to set at T minus
ETA
times this gradient
and this is equals to Theta T minus one
over n times VT
while back wire had tea
and
okay so now there is a little bit kind
of like small
um thing here so suppose you say
you give a name called this BT so then
this is
let's say
etern over and
so this is Theta t
ability
so I'm going to try to
um okay so what's the our goal our goal
is try to do kind of recursion for the
Y's that's what we did before right a
good question for the wise
and how do I get a recursion for the Y's
I have to look at how that why changes
right what's what is the why this is one
entry of the y y hat uh I the output at
time t plus one
um but I also write this as a something
like related to the time my time the the
function output item T so how do I do
that this is a non-linear function
before we just you know do a linear
multiplication because before we just
know that
uh if this is G If This Were G then this
is just equals to Phi times Theta Theta
t plus one right if if this F was was G
but if it but because this is non-linear
we have to do something so what we do is
we try to Taylor expand
at time t
so that you can have a relationship
between
uh Theta T and Theta t plus one
so if a Taylor expanded you have to
write the gradient of F7
t x i
and times the differences between
the two iterate and plus some something
high order right and and if you look at
what's the difference the difference is
a function of ETA right the difference
is exactly this ETA BT
so that's why we can write
plus the gradient let's take a t x i
times minus ETA b t
and plus the second other term will be
quadratic in the this will be quadratic
in this way if I'm going to write it
somewhat
um
informally and and more formally I can
write this as
something
a function of like ETA Square times
something
because the the difference has a ETA in
it so that's why you square it you get
ETA Square so in sometimes this is a
term I want to ignore
I'm trying I'm trying very hard here
just because I want to ignore this term
because and the reason why to ignore it
is because it's ETA square right so so
uh so basically what I'm going to say is
that I'm T the constant you know is not
a function of it's not a function of
of ETA so if you fix everything else and
just take ETA to be very small so if you
take ETA
to go to zero then the second other term
the ETA square m t term
is negligible
we can do this more formally but I don't
want to go into so much uh dragons but
there's a way for you to kind of bound
empty by something right whatever you
want it right so you get the bond for m
key and then you just say that if ETA is
small enough so that ETA Square band
becomes negligible that's that's
basically how you formally do it so
so if you ignore this this second term
then everything becomes so simple right
so for now
uh Let's ignore the second another term
then what you have is that why
t plus one
this is equals to
if you put all put this equation let's
call this equation three in Vector form
Vector form then you get YT y hat t plus
1 is equals to y height T because this
is y High T
and plus this linear function of BT
right so what is this this is really
ETA
um
minus ETA times
uh Phi
transpose
feed transpose
times BT
I guess actually this is uh right so yes
V transpose times BT
and then plus something like
ETA Square Times some constant
I'm gonna keep this just for a little
bit so that
um but but essentially I want to ignore
it and
and then you can rewrite this as well
how T minus ETA V transpose and what is
BT BT is this difference between prime
is this something like this but let's
you let's go back to that so
this fee
uh
wait I'm not sure why I'm missing look
constant here
oh I see I see so
I think this one over and
I guess there's some mismatch in my
notes like a but it doesn't matter so
let's have the one button here well like
like for the linear regression case I
didn't have the one over in the last
function and now I have the one over and
that's why it's a little bit mismatched
but it's not a fundamental
difference so
um
so let's have the well and then you have
this is actually this is VT
so this is 50
and then you have
ETA v t
transpose
times y y
minus y height t
times one over n
um
maybe let me okay how do I do this
so let me ignore the one over n
fiber because you know you can you can
redefine the loss function whatever you
want right like let's say just we don't
have one of them in the last one sorry
so
um
so
then you have this and then this becomes
um
if you
subtract
right back from
from both of this
and then you will organize this
so you're gonna get
this is equals to I minus ETA v t
transpose
by
at T minus y black
I think there's somehow there's a little
bit problem with the
there's a little bit I think this is a
plus this is a plus
right okay but the point is that you
know basically if you compare this
equation
uh I guess technically you still have
some
ETA Square term
which we don't care uh if you compare
this equation with the recursion before
the recursion before was this
uh actually maybe here
the only difference is that this Matrix
is different
but before you are multiplying with a
fixed Matrix Fifi transpose and now you
are using
VT VT transpose
so so
um but you know everything could be the
same if this VT but you don't
necessarily need it to be the same right
in our original proof you only need this
Matrix to be
uh smaller you only need I minus etel
Fifi transpose this Matrix to be smaller
than identity
right so suppose we ignore
the ETA square m term
um because in second order and then
suppose
um Theta T minus zero
suppose you are in within Sigma
for a beta
at time t
and then suppose okay so suppose you are
not far far away from the let's say that
zero okay so then you know that VT minus
Phi
but in two Norm is less than Sigma over
four this is by
ellipsislessness
coffee this is our assumption
and that means that Sigma mean
of VT is
not very different from the sigma mu Phi
say minus Sigma over four this is larger
than 3 4 times Sigma
so Sigma mean of v t is also good
so so you so so the eigenvalue so you
still have a lower Bound for the
eigenvalue it's just a little bit weaker
up to a constant Factor
and that means that I minus ETA v t
transpose
operator Norm
is less than
1 minus ETA times 3 over 4 times Sigma
right so very similar to the before
and then uh so but there is an
assumption here so so this sounds great
right there but there is a assumption
which is that Theta T is not very far
away from so that's zero this is
something you cannot take for granted
you have to prove it is the case so
that's why we have to inductively
so basically the only thing left is that
we need to
inductively
prove
this proves that t
minus 0 is never too big
that's uh basically that's the
that's the thing and
and in some sense this is expected
because you need
uh this is expected because in some
sense this is expected
because
um recall that the autocader had the two
Norm
say the Hat was the the global minimizer
like we this is the
Global mean that we constructed
in the last
lecture so we said that there is a
global mean of size squared and over
Sigma
right so and and and because there's a
global mean with this size and if this
is much much less than Sigma over 4 beta
right so when
Sigma
beta over Sigma square is sufficiently
small
right so so I guess this
over Sigma is very sufficient small then
you have this in equality and that means
that there exists a global mean within
this region Sigma over 4 beta if there
exist a global mean within this region y
used to leave this region right that's
why you should somewhat expect that it's
always in within this region
um
and how do we formally do this I think
you just say uh formally
you just do an induction right because
you know that
um I guess square root
we know that
one over n
let me see when I made the mistake here
so one
over square root and times
where I had T minus y
what
uh
zero this is of one because every answer
is on the order of all fun so you have
an entries so here and then inductively
you can show that
you can show this implies that
we actually have you know exponential
decay of error but actually even you
don't care about that you still have
for every time you have this
and for if for every time T you have
this then it means that
um
passcode and
V Sigma T minus Sigma hat
two Norm is less than
o of one because it's Theta hat is the
the ground shoots right so this is
because
fee Theta hat is equals to Y back
to the height is the construct with the
one that we constantly lost the lecture
and then this means the Theta T minus
Theta hat
two Norm is less than squared and over
Sigma which is exactly right you are
saying that your
your
um
your uh iterate is not very far away
from your targets that I had
and then you also know that your targets
that I had is also not very far away
from
so we also know that
the target this is also less than
uh I guess there's a big O here
Big O squared and over Sigma
because
um this is what we did last time
and then by triangle inequality
we got Theta T minus Theta zero
is less than
30 minutes later hat
say sorry zero
so now which is less than or square root
and sigma
and this is less than Sigma over 4 beta
if beta over Sigma squared is less than
much much less than 1 over square rooted
so so this is how you inductively
maintain uh the distance between say
that how do inductively show that
um
Theta T is not very far away from zero
zero
yeah the the the step sounds a little
bit complicated but actually the
intuition is very simple it's just that
you
like there are probably many ways to
prove this like I I just presented one
way so like there's already a global
minimal there right so there shouldn't
be any ways for you to
um leave and and what you do is
basically you say that you have a set of
hat here you'll say that zero you know
that these two are
the distance between these two is of
squared and over Sigma
and and you are optimizing and in some
sense that your head is your target
right because of the headaches has the
great the best fitting so you're someone
moving even closer to set a height so
why not you should have even bigger
distance eventually afterwards right so
so so so so so that's that's why
um uh that's why this is working right
so if you look at the iterate I think
you are somewhat moving to see the Hat
so okay so enough out of all of this
right so then we got this
equality
and with this equality we got that
y back t plus one minus y back
y height t plus one minus y is less than
T minus y back two Norm minus ETA
times three over four Sigma Square and
then you can do a recursion to get
exponential decay of error
okay any questions
I think I made a small typo somewhere in
the Assumption of the
theorem I need to fix that
I think my assumption should be that
this is less than C over square root and
and it doesn't really matter because you
can make better Instinct if you change
as we see last time right you can make
either of them with bigger or the alpha
bigger you can make beta over Sigma
Square arbitrary small two small so
um so it doesn't really matter that much
any questions
sure
[Music]
okay
[Music]
thank you so I guess you know I think I
there's one word like let me rephrase
your question and let me know if it's
not uh what you asked so I guess one
question you could ask is that whether
you really rely on the exponential decay
for the kernel case to to have this
relationship between Network and kernel
I think the answer to that is no
um so so the second type of approach
that I some would alternate last time
but didn't really go into detail better
approach doesn't require
that you have exponential decay of error
so in that case both the kernel and new
network you can only show them to have
some polynomial speed of Decay mode like
the error is polynomial in t so you can
still make this relationship so so
exponential decay is not
um it's not that important but I think
this is actually something that people
realize after the first few papers at
the very beginning
on the very first paper using this
exponential thing and and people thought
that because you have expandable
Converse so fast that's why you don't
leave this neighborhood but I think you
can do something so that even without
explaining your Decay you still don't
leave the neighborhood because when they
will leave the neighborhood
probably depends most on whether in the
neighborhood there is is a global
minimum
if there is a global minimum in the
neighborhood but somehow you cannot
converge to it exponentially fast that's
still probably fine as long as you
converts to it eventually
right so
um I'm not sure whether that's what you
asked
but I think
here you want to cover this kind of stay
close
right right you do want to say and also
you want to
you know you want to characterize the
dynamite works right so if they don't
have the same property right you and you
somehow can't optimize can analyze the
optimization of nice works that's fine
but but I think though but then but it
becomes true but the the relationship is
something to help us to to bridge the
the gap between what we knew and what we
don't know right so the new networks is
something we didn't know but uh the the
kernel wise something we knew and and
and if they are similar then you can
hope to analyze the new network right
um
yeah so I think that's that's why we so
they are doing something similar
okay all right I think that's
[Applause]
um
I think I have a little bit more things
to to add about the newer tangent kernel
I guess we've discussed this many times
like the limitation of neurotangent
Kernel is that you only
at most do as well as the kernel method
right so so they are kind of um so
basically question is you know how
how well a kernel method can work
right so are we really characterizing
the power of deep learning right if deep
learning is only doing as well as
kernels
is it really is it good or not bad right
so another I think is that at least I
think most people believe in this the
answer is that new network can do much
better things than kernels
um and and this characterization of the
new network as kernels is not uh
characterizing the true power of the
network
and you can you can try to you know say
this you know in various ways
um so there are very a lot of papers
that tries to do this right so beyond
the ntk approach I guess if you search
Beyond ntk or Beyond lazy training
you'll see a bunch of papers including
some of my papers
um so so we try to analyze deep learning
in different regime
um but there is there's a simple
separation if you don't care about the
optimization performance if you just
care about the power of the the
regularization and the under under the
the
um if you only have a statistic aspect
you can easily show that new network can
do better things than kernels and this
is um
uh this is a um example so the example
is something like this
so
so I guess this is the example where
foreign
statistically
Limited
so
um
and in some sense the intuition is that
the limitation comes from that
the kernel the kernel
of the features
are fixed
in the ntk approach you don't have any
adaptive adaptivity to the data so your
data probably wants to use some features
but but you are using a fixed feature
for for your data so and and this is a
simple case where you have to have set a
concrete example so so suppose you
consider
this case where X is in say Rd
and and Y is in plus one minus one
and let's say each of the X i's are just
a uniform
like IED gaussian so x i is if example
is index
the superscript is for the examples and
the subscript is for the for the
dimension
and and let's say Y is equals to X1 X2
so you have a very simple function which
is just learning the product of the
first two dimension of the data
so if you draw this suppose this is X1
this is X2 then you just have
four different combinations and this is
a positive example this is an active
example positive example and this is
negative and this is negative
so this is not linearly separable
because you have this
four points that are positioned like
this so you have to use a non-linear
model
um or a linear model on some feature
space right so if you use cinematic
works
and suppose you uh regularize suppose
you regularize
on the L2 Norm
and this is equivalent to
to regularize
on this Norm that we discussed right
this Norm C Theta which is something
like sum of
um
AI
WI
I'm not sure whether you still remember
this whereas when we have this invite
work which is y is equals to something
like sum of AI Sigma W I transpose X and
you can Define this complexity measure
which is the kind of like the path Norm
right and and and we have shown that
regularizing L2 Norm of the other
parameters is the same as regularizing
this somewhat complex you know which and
which gives the actually the complexity
the optimization guarantees right
so we have discussed this and in some
sense and suppose you uh use the right
works then what you'll find is so the
best solution
but but by the best solution I mean the
minimum Norm solution the minimum
Norm Solutions
is a is a sparse one right is um uses
a sparse combination
of neurons
so basically the best solution actually
you can in this case you can exactly
compute what's the best solution I'm not
going to prove it but I think it's
something relatively believable
um so so the best solution first of all
doesn't really use any other dimensions
that seems to be believable right why
you want to use any other dimensions if
your function is only the first function
of the first two dimensions and you only
have to use something about the first
two Dimensions you only need the
following
uh four neurons so one neuron computes
X1 plus X2
and another neuron compute
minus X1 minus X2
and leaving another neuron compute that
computes the value of X1 minus X2
another one that computes the value of
X2 minus X1
so I claim that this is actually equals
to the function and if you want to
verify that I can briefly do that so
value of x value of t
plus value of minus t
this is equal to absolute value of t
so so this is equals to X1 plus X2
minus x square minus X2
and and now I claim that this is
actually equals to X1 times X2
when x minus X2 are both binary and and
how do you see this I guess the only way
I can see this is just
like try all the four combinations right
if X1 X2 are have the same sign then
this will becomes zero and this will
becomes one
right if I explained X2 are either both
while both minus one and that's is the
case when X1 X2 the power that is one
and if X1 X will have difference on the
first term is zero and the second term
becomes
uh one
wait why I'm not why I'm having a half
here oh yes and second term becomes two
right so right so and you multiply half
you get minus one right so
good so so basically if you use new
network and you you recognize we can
show that this is the solution fund
which is a various sparse combination of
a a small number of features in some
sense when you use regularization you
find these four features and you do a
linear combination
so so these four features are the right
features for this task
however if you use um ntk suppose you
use ntk
suppose using ntk
then what you do is you just don't you
don't learn any features you just try to
um uh do a do a L2 you do a dance
combination of your existing features
right so so
um
um in some sense what you do is you say
um
I guess how do I say this in the best
way so
so basically when you do ntk what you
learn is something like uh
um
sorry why I'm not
[Applause]
I guess I guess I can see the serum but
uh I think the roughly the intuition is
that your why will be your prediction
will be something like a sum of AI Sigma
W I transpose X
um or maybe a maybe something like this
some of AI times
fee of
X
right and and there are a bunch of
features and each feature is VI and and
these features
uh use
all the
dimensions
you know this depends of course exactly
what the features are depends on what
kernels you are using if you use
anti-curve kernel you're going to get
some feature Vector if you use random
kernel you get some other feature
um uh some other features but whatever
features you do uh this is always the
function of all the data right so
there's no
uh uh like uh you cannot specialize to a
special subset of features and and also
because you are doing a regularization
on the out minimum L2 Norm solution for
the coefficient in front of the feature
you don't prefer any sparse solution
right so so recall that
um
yeah sorry I'm
I'm using the wrong version of notes so
I guess I have to improvise a little bit
so so if you look at ntk what you do is
you try to minimize
the L2 Norm of this Vector a such that
the data sum of AI
vix is equals to y
maybe philosophy
right so and if you do the new right
work
I think we have claimed that pneumatic
work is the same as L1 as VM in the
kernel space so then the corresponding
thing would be you minimize the L1 Norm
of a such that the sum of a i v i x j
is equals to y j
so in some sense when you do the right
works and you have a you have a lot of
features and you're choosing the
subsider features a sparse subset
features and we'll do ntk you are
minimizing I O2 Norm that never gives
you sparse uh combinations it's actually
prefers dense combination it's the
reverse Direction you want a smooth
combinations of the existing features as
possible so that's why you have to pay
um more samples to if you use ntk
because you are using kind of
sub-optimal features and this can be
proved in in this case like you can
prove that
um this is a theorem
where you can prove that
kernel method
with ntk kernel
requires
and to be Omega of d square samples
uh to
to learn a problem
with uh less than with arrow less than
one
and and in contrast
uh regularized Network only need
internet
only need
and is equal to all of the samples
any questions about this I think this
part is a little bit kind of like handy
baby because I didn't want to go into
all the details and also this depends a
little bit on what we discussed in the
past right so that what I want svm
connections onto the on to the
um the connection between our svm and
right works
any questions
so I guess maybe maybe the just to wrap
up this once again so so basically if
you do
new network with regularization then you
are we have shown that this is
equivalent to
um doing io1 and CVM in a feature space
you are trying to find a sparse
combination of features that place your
data right and in this particular
example This concerns
for the intuitive that finding a sparse
combination is useful because not all
the features are equally useful right so
these features we designed are much
better features than a random feature
so and that's why
you might work with regularization could
have good sample complexity
and on the other hand when you do ntk
kernel only on most of the other kernels
so you are not trying to find the sparse
combination of the features if you're
trying to find a dance combination of
the features because you are doing ll2
uh you're finding a minimum L2 no
absolution
and and the features and each of the
features is a function of all the data
all the coordinates of the data point so
so the features are you know not that
useful in some sense there's a lot of
noise in your features you have to rely
on averaging all the noise over multiple
features to to learn something you can
still learn something but it's going to
be less efficient
um
right I think that's the summary
foreign
there's no other questions I'm going to
move on to the next topic
which is about
implicit
regularization effect
I'm not sure whether you still remember
what we discussed in the mystery of the
deep learning series section so I'm
going to briefly repeat the kind of the
high level goal here so the kind of the
observation we had about the empirical
deep learning is that we found that
there are multiple
on global Minima
of China laws exist
and and the optimizers
have some preference
have some
implicit preferences
and we have claimed that you know almost
every aspect of the optimizers have some
preferences for example if you use the
particular initialization
that enables ntk then you have the ntk
preferences you are learning the the ntk
solution
and if you use some other initialization
you have some other preferences and we
have kind of concluded that you know if
the integral solution is the wrong
preferences right so like you you don't
do much Beyond a kernel method you
actually do exactly the same as kernel
method so so basically that means you
are finding the wrong Global minimum
that doesn't necessarily generalize as
well as other Global minimum so so from
now on we're going to try to look at
other Global Minima of this objective
and see what other optimizers you know
prefer
so if you use default meter you may
prefer a solution that is different from
the NGK solution
oh yeah what would that means
right right so so so why I call ntk
initialization right so
um so the antique so
this is the anti-kinetization basically
I mean the initialization under which
you can prove the anti-kare result
so maybe specifically I think last time
we we have two examples right so one
example is
um
maybe maybe the the this example is
right right
so so for example I think just when we
have the weight thing right so like
where there is a
like uh
something like here I think we have this
over parameters model we have this with
and we initialize with AI to be plus one
minus one and w i to be this spherical
gaussian and you can for example
initialize something with something much
smaller
right and actually you should right if
you really do the experiments for this
exactly parametization you should
initialize
both either AI or WIS um like maybe a
one like some like square root and
Factor smaller and then you're going to
see much different empirical results and
actually we have done this you know in
the in actually in the paper uh you know
many people have done this like it's
relatively simple experiments so so here
you can say the initialization is the
the corporate right so uh for the other
case I think when you change the
parametization to see the antique regime
I think you can say the the
parametization is the corporate and it
and also even in this case where even
it's supposed to initialize the same as
ntk suppose you do stochastic winning
descent you have sufficiently large
stochastic it doesn't have to be super
large but but a little bit larger than
zero then you will leave that
initialization area you're going to
convert some other places so that's
another way to relieve ntk region
so so we're gonna sometimes discuss this
other kind of like
ways to basically what we're going to
discuss next are either using transition
to leave ntk or use sarcasticity and
what else you can also
um
I use the
um the learning rate uh the learning
rate too learning rate is kind of almost
the same as stochasticity because if you
have larger learning rate in some sense
and you have sud then your stochasticity
is bigger
so
um
right so so the first thing I want to do
is the the factor from Equalization the
the implicit organization effect from
initialization
the first is this effect
of initialization
and you will see that in certain cases
you you can leave I'm you know with with
us we don't necessarily really care
about leaving ntk we really care about
like having a better generalization
right so that means you have to live on
Decay but you have to do probably more
than that
um to get better generalization
so
um and so this is what we're gonna do
this lack the next 15 minutes of this
lecture and the next lecture the effect
of initialization
and
um I'm going to start with a simple case
where you have over parametrized
um over parameters linear regression
case
you need the over parametricization
because you need
especially if you consider linear models
right the one of the important thing is
that you have to have multiple Global
minimum otherwise there's no so-called
implicit organization effect
right because optimizers have to convert
to Global minimum you have to have
multiple Global minerals so that the
optimizers can have a choice to choose
between them so so that's why we need
over parametric regression so that you
have multiple Global minimum actually
there is an infinite number of global
minimum where you have over
parametration
so and we'll see that in this case
um small initialization
prefers
a low Norm solution
and this is also the case when we in the
next lecture we're going to go beyond
linear model and the the high level
conclusion is the same if you small
initialization then you prefer a lower
Norm solution
so and today we're only going to you
know in the next 15 minutes when we're
only going to do the linear models so
and this is actually not that hard so
um let's set up first
so this is a standard linear regression
case you have
something like
I guess for this lecture I'm using the
lower subscript for the uh for the
number of examples just because you
should really look up any linear
regression book then they use
subscript for examples so and here we
don't so this
so so each of these X i's are examples
example I and you put them into a matrix
and let's assume X is full rank
so means rank n
and let's also assume n is much smaller
than d
okay so and and we have a parameter
beta
so you get a loss function
y back minus X beta
to Norm Square let's see I have a half
here just for convenience
this is the main particles
okay so this is standard linear
regression and I know indeed L hat beta
has
infinite
number
of
Global mean
and you actually can characterize
exactly what that Global means are
and so and other Global means with error
with loss zero
so what are the global means so beta
is equals to supposed to take beta to be
X
pseudo inverse times y back plus
some
Vector Zeta
where
Zeta is any Vector that is also also
normal
also orthogonal 2x1 up to x n
is a global mean
so as also your beta has this form then
it's a global mean and these are
actually all the global mean
so
um and actually here
I think last time someone asked about
pseudo inverse maybe let me have a some
quickly some basic properties of
pseudonym words
uh I guess my
my way of thinking about it is probably
slightly different from
the Wikipedia so the way I always think
about student universe is the following
so I always think about it when when
there's a in ICD because with that SVD I
can verify everything so that I don't
have to remember them
so so suppose you have a matrix X in
dimension and by D
and suppose X is of rank r
of course R has to be less than either n
both less than and less than d
um so the way how I do uh how I remember
every property of super inverse is the
following so I consider X
SVD of X which is U Sigma V transpose
and sigma is of Dimension R by R let's
say you you ignore all the non-zero
entries so an U is of Dimension say and
by r and v is of dimension
on D by r
so then you know that um the column span
of U is the same as the column span
of x
and the Rose Band
sorry the column span
of V because there's a transpose here
right so column span of B
is the Rose Band
of x
and also you know that the pseudo
inverse
in this notation is you can think of as
Define to be V Sigma inverse
U transpose so here all the sigma
so here's Sigma is a diagonal matrix
with anxious Sigma 1 up to Sigma r
and sigma i's are all positive
so
so then this inverse is well defined and
X2 inverse is just this V Sigma inverse
U transpose and now if you want to
understand what's the probability of the
pseudo inverse you can verify yourself
so you know x x should be inverse this
is gonna be what this is gonna be U
Sigma
V transpose V Sigma inverse U transpose
V transpose B is identity
um so
so U
transpose
right because B transpose V is identity
Sigma times Sigma inverse is identity so
what is this this is the projection
to the column span
of X of x
right it's the projection of to the
constant of U and the column spell for U
is the same as the column span of x
and X through the inverse times x
this is equal if you do the same
calculation it's going to be equals to
V Sigma inverse U transpose times U
Sigma V transpose which is VV transpose
which is the projection so the row span
of X and you can also see the dimension
matches because this is a matrix of
dimension
d by D and and and V and it goes by the
rows of a v is in in dimension d
I'm sorry the the rows of axis in
dimension D the column to V is in
dimension d so
um right and in the case when you have
so
in the in this case in this case where X
is in
and by D then you know under the rank is
n
then you know that on x x to the inverse
is the projection
to the column span
of X and the column spell of X now is
full the full span of all the vectors
but column span is right the column
spine is the spell of the
uh
uh right it's all the vectors so that's
why this is just identity
and
an X pseudo inverse X
this is the production of row spun
of X so how many rows they are there are
rows of X and they don't spend
everything because the dimension D is
bigger so you cannot spell everything so
that's that's why this is not identity
this is really just the
the projection of the Rose trans you
cannot simplify more
right
Okay so
it's a little bit too long I guess as a
as a building block but okay I hope this
helps like this is how I understand this
is pseudo Universe like I I never
remember what x axial inverse is equals
to so this this is how I remember
um
so and and the question okay so now we
have so many Global Minima right so and
okay I think with this it's easy to
verify this is our Global minimum
because you can verify
um this beta is global minimum because
you can say take X beta which is equals
to x x to the inverse y back plus X Zeta
the data is orthogonal to the rows of X
so that's why x0 is zero
so you get x x to the inverse y back and
x axis inverse in this case is that
identity so you get the Y back right I
just claim that x x to the inverse is
identity
okay so so that's why X beta is equal to
5x that's why it's a global minimum and
the question is which global mineral
you're gonna converts to
so
um my theorem is that the theorem
is that if you initialize so green
descent
on L has beta
was
initialization
beta0 is equals to zero
um and suppression is smaller than rate
and the rate
actually you know exactly how small it
is like I just don't want to give you
too too much Dragon
um so so if you have Learners small
enough and the neutralization is zero
then this converges to
uh the minimum solution
so the minimum solution beta hat is
defined to be
the one among all Global minimum
where the speed of Norm solution among
our Global minimum of the loss function
so basically you get this two Norm for
free right you're minimizing this
you need to say that I want to have the
minimum normal solution you just say I
want to do any descent but you get a
minimum solution for free
and and the reason why you got it is
because you you express your implicit
preferences through the initialization
Okay cool so
yeah I think I have five minutes which
is perfect for the proof sketch
so
um
sketch I guess this is actually really
approved but I just uh I I think I
ignore some small details that's why I
call it a sketch so the first step is
that if you do standard
convex optimization
you know that
this goes to zero as T goes to Infinity
right you know that if you run for a
long time then you your loss will become
zero
that's you know I'm not going to show
how do you do this but this is uh you
can invoke any off-the-shelf
optimization results
and the second thing is that you know
that
it's better hat is actually equals to x
x
dagger x x to the inverse times y back
right so so we know that
all of these are Global minimum but if
you you take Zeta to be zero then that's
the uh
if you take
sorry I think I'm
just if you take zero to be zero then
that's the minimum solution I think this
is this there's no X here
and and this is can also be simply
simply verified because if you take any
beta
so for any data
orthogonal to X1 up to x n
then you look at x to the inverse y back
plus Zeta the two Norm of this
this is equals to
x to the inverse wire back to Norm plus
Zeta to Norm plus two times x to the
inverse back Theta
and this is larger than x to the inverse
y back two Norm Square
plus 0 because the norm is less than
zero and this
quantity
is just equals to
zero
because
see why this is equal to zero this is
equals to zero because
I guess this is maybe let's say this is
equals two times y back
um
X
so what's this this is
Zeta transpose x to the inverse wave
back right
and I claim that this is equals to x to
the inverse point back to normal
because this is zero and why this is
zero I guess
um this is actually a good way to
practice what I had so x to the inverse
is V
Sigma inverse U transpose sorry U said
wait pseudo inverse is V Sigma inverse U
transpose
so the
the columns
span of X inverse is the same as the
Rose one of X right so and
Zeta okay sorry this is transpose not
this
Zeta is orthogonal
to the rows of X so which means that
Zeta is orthogonal to the column
of x to the universe right so that's why
Zeta times this is the Zeta times The
Columns of
of the of the pseudo inverse so so
that's why everything is zero right so
this is zero
so Zeta is our sock node too
column span
of X2 inverse which is equals to the row
span
of x
okay all right so so so basically you
see that in the norm is only decreasing
if you set as Delta Zeta to be zero
that's why
when zero is zero that's the minimum
solution
right so three
I guess this is this one to our base a
basic facts about this linear regression
thing
um the three is what's really about the
optimization so you can prove that beta
t
is in a span
of X1 up to X N you can prove this
inductively
and why this is the case this is a super
simple induction because beta T is
equals to Beta t plus 1 is equal to Beta
T minus ETA times the gradient
and there are t and it goes to the
gradient
the gradient is X transpose
y back minus X beta
so this is
in the column span
of X transpose
and so
so it's also in the low span
of x
right so so basically your update is
always in your spine of X that's why you
never leave the spine right so and
better by the way better so maybe I
should start with the
the better zero is in this but the zero
is zero is in the span
of X1 abstraction
and each time you update that update is
the spell X1 after accent so by
induction you get that you're always in
display
so basically then so far because you're
always in a span
right so the only solution
solution
to L at beta0
in the Span in the span
is
this
right because what are the solutions
um with either zero the solutions with
arrow 0 are these ones
and guys are
on this one that's right so this has
solution zero
and and among this you know who has who
are in the span of the real spell of X
right so only this one has is in the
real spell facts because all of these
are not in the little smile facts they
are orthogonal stereo specifics so the
only solution that is in the real space
of x
is is just a the first term we just take
the first term
so and that happens to be the minimum
solution and that's why
um you you get a minimum solution
and sometimes basically all the magic
comes from this right so basically this
is a regularization in sometimes this is
a
this is a constraint imposed by the
algorithm the algorithm say that you
cannot go everywhere the algorithm say
you can only go to those places where in
a span of the data so that's why you
have to
um stay in a smile of the data and it
happens that in the span of the data
there's only one solution and that
solution is the minimum solution
right
so I think in some sense the if I draw a
picture okay I guess I'm running late
but real quick so if I draw a picture I
think the this is a very difficult
picture to draw but I think you can
still try it so if you you have a
um
you can have a maybe I say this this
blue Direction
this is the spell of the data let's say
suppose we will have sometimes one data
so the direction of the span of the data
is only one dimensional
and
and then you have a
a Subspace of solutions
which are orthogonal so this is
orthogonal here
to the span right this is this this is
the
this is the solution where you have this
right so it's orthogonal to the smell of
the data and the intersection part is
the the target solution so the
intersection
the
the intersection part is really access
to the universe playback
and
and so you start with this
you try to reach this purple plane
because that's the optimization wants to
do the optimization wants to reach the
purple plane
but optimization also say you can only
go in the the blue Direction
and so that's why you meet in the
interception and the intersection is the
closest point to the origin
okay I guess that's oh yeah
yeah so do you need a condition that you
have to spend on the on a span right so
yes you do because if you don't spend
suppose for example what you supposed to
start here
so what happens is that you
can only move in this direction
that's what the the algorithm says right
the algorithm says the update isn't
expand so you can only all your changes
is in the spot so you could you can only
move it so basically you basically go in
this way until you hit here
so then this place is not the minimum of
social anymore
this place is going to have some higher
Norm than
the ideal point
yes and yes so you can say the
impressive acquisition effect always
happens but the effect is in the minimum
no solution only if your initialization
is zero
like you always have a preferences right
so whatever you do with initialization
you have some preferences about which
global minimum you want to convert to
right but if you want the preferences to
be the minimum solution then you really
have to choose uh zero is the
initialization
any other questions
right now
it'll still be able to solved back
right so so the question is whether
there's any hope that this can transfer
to nonlinear cases I think
here we are using a lot of things about
linear algebra right so we know we know
what is the minimum solution so and so
forth we have the orthogonality
everything right so we have
non-linearity you don't have most of
this
um so so those parts that we discussed
about the very highly linear algebra in
the algebraic part those don't transfer
at all probably
um but somehow at least we can find one
other situation where we have nonlinear
models you can still do
uh you still prefer the minimum solution
and that's that's next lecture yeah so
but but the mechanism is somehow it's
not exactly the same the only so next
action and this lecture that the only
connections is that the the final
um the final message of similar or is
the same but the techniques are quite
different we still don't know how to
unify them in a right way
um
[Music]
[Music]
right yeah
yeah I'm wondering if
you might be learning a little bit
smaller
yeah yeah so so you're absolutely right
so like the the difficult case come from
the very very small generate case I
think even a testable small in red case
so even for infant test most modeling
rate
um like so it's basically have a
differential equation right you just
have a trajectory and
um and you want to know where the trade
actually goes right so I as far as I
know like uh you know I'm not a I don't
know too much about differential
equations but I think the problem is how
to solve that equation like like you
know they create the solution exists
that you know there's a trajectory but
what's the where the structure really
goes that's the hard part I don't think
we
at least I'm not aware of any
papers that use the tools from
differential equations
uh heavily right so this is a useful
language right so you can look from the
language like the the formulation of the
language perspective the differential
equations language are very useful
um but
typically the hard part is how do you
solve it
in some cases you can I think I know one
paper where you can solve it but but
it's not like it's using the structure
of the problem you have to literally
solve it using some new math it's not
like you can invoke a theorem in in the
differential equation literature say
this kind of questions can all be solved
I don't think so
okay sounds great okay cool see you next
week